[Music]
ruth is in cleveland ohio hi ruth
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure how
can we help
well my husband and i have been married
for 29 years but we've always had one
problem extended family
you're the only ones
well my husband came from welfare and
got his college education and then i
came from the opposite side of the track
but both sides of the family has always
had money problems
and um
we've been having problems
understanding that our biblical
responsibilities are to family
and it got so bad at one point when we
were 45 we looked around and discovered
that we had less than 100 000 in our
401k we had 80 000 on credit card debts
and a big mortgage
so we said to our family just without a
stop we're being ruined
and so we spent a lot of years we've had
700 000 in our 401k
we're down to the left 4 000 on a credit
card and we have 11 000 emergency funds
so we were going to be debt-free this
year and our mortgage was paid off
then we said we're doing great then the
family emergencies happened again
his parents are in their mid 70s very
bad health
and ray his sister and her two daughters
all ended up homeless at the end of the
year
so
we grabbed a 30 000 loan out of our 401k
bought a manufactured home for them a
three bedroom threw them all in it and
got our name off of it because we didn't
want to be legally
drowned with them
and then just other emergencies happened
and our 11 000 emergency fund
um drained also part of that was us we
had a
basement leak so that was six thousand
dollars for watercolor how old are you
i'm 55 and that's what happened how old
is your husband
55. so what are you all gonna what are
y'all going to stop this
exactly but how can we walk away from
family is it biblically
especially as parents no
biblically you are biblically there is
no mandate for you to
support misbehavior
if my
listen if your mother is doing cocaine
you are not biblically obligated to buy
it
true if your mother is misbehaving and
won't work you're not biblically
obligated to buy her food
not biblically
absolutely not biblically those that
won't work don't let them eat paul said
do you remember reading that
yes but now his parents are too old to
work and they're very sick yeah that's
not what i'm talking about you said
biblically
let's solve that first because you've
got to quit blaming the bible for your
lack of boundaries
okay
it's not the bible's fault you can honor
the position of father honor your father
and mother remember ten commandments
okay
you honor the office of father and
mother but not the misbehavior of father
and mother
okay if your father raped someone you
wouldn't honor that
oh no okay
you don't so you honor you but you can
still honor the office of fatherhood
okay you follow me in the office of
father the office of mother so we can
honor your mom and dad
even though they have misbehaved and
even though they're now let's move past
the bible then and say okay
from an emotional standpoint they need
some food am i going to go buy them some
food if i have 700 000
yes i am
okay
right no question am i going to give
them a house probably not
am i going to make them am i going to
make them get on a budget and live
within their social security income
why as a part of uh the me loving them
well as an ob you know if i'm going to
give you money you're going to do what i
say
with this stuff but you're just throwing
you're just giving a drunk a drink for
25 years
you're enablers
well we thought we were saving families
like when we paid the property taxes for
his brothers it didn't work for
actually his brother did get out of
everything and now he's a truck driver
and they're doing well okay so you did
help them
you you enabled them to do better
instead of enabling their misbehavior
right but no one else is doing better
okay so what's the the reason is is you
require if you give someone that has an
alcohol problem that that you have you
have a process in place that they don't
spend it on alcohol
i'm using that as a metaphor you
understand right right yes i do all
right so you you're sweet people you're
kind people and and by the way ramses
are kind people
we just understand boundaries
and ruth it's it's taking you and your
husband your heart for for wanting to
help right
you've done it in a misdirected way
um but still taking that spirit of
helping
and
whether that's through teaching whether
that's through hey you're going to go
through this class
whatever
you put up
um there's a way to still to still help
and love them by not just funneling them
money constantly so who who else are you
who else are you guys
who who is dependent upon you right now
in your family
um
my husband's parents his sister
her two 20-year-old daughter why don't
they work um
they are emotionally
damaged or get counseling and too shy to
interview yeah they need to get a job
now yeah honestly we would have been
okay not helping them but
because we did say stop when we turned
45 but
then when his parents became too ill
we're like well we can't leave them out
on the street being that ill yeah well
but yeah but if i'm going to help them
the other people don't get to live with
them
we were hoping that they would take care
of his parents
no you weren't
you didn't have no intelligent person i
already know these people well enough to
know they're not going to do that
and you are you know them a lot better
than i do
true they're too shy and they're too
deep into counseling to go out of the
house and get a job and you thought they
were going to take care of someone
you didn't really think that
well we thought if we threw them all
together they could kind of help each
other
oh darling that was a bad hypothesis
we're gonna put a bunch of broken things
together and it's gonna make one fixed
thing
i don't think so
okay so you guys have got listen i'm
gonna send you a book called boundaries
by dr henry cloud
and i want you to
lovingly kindly and firmly
start helping people
not throwing money at them
and helping them means you move them
like you did the one brother-in-law to
sustainability
every move that you make with money has
to move them towards standing on their
own
all right and some people that may mean
not giving money to
and just letting them
be what comes yeah yeah
magically 20 year olds
magically 20 year olds who get hungry
will go get a job it's magical
true very true
they'll bust through their trauma and
it'll be amazing or they'll end up in an
institution or something because they
truly have a mental illness at a level
that they don't need to be living down
with broken down 75 year olds
right right that's actually true too
yeah so one of the two they need to get
up get they need to paint or get off the
ladder they're 20.
and they're parasites they're parasites
so it's time
it's not good for them
what has been modeled
what his dysfunctional family it's his
family what his dysfunctional family is
modeled to these two 20 year olds is
horrible
yes
and it's done them a disservice that's
what enabling always does it's a
disservice yeah so i know their problems
aren't real and all of that but you have
to learn i mean i want you to love them
i just want you to love them well
and thoroughly and with wisdom
and kindness and firmness
and um all you've done is just kindness
only
and it hasn't resulted in what you
wanted that's why you called the book is
boundaries by dr henry cloud hold on
we'll send it